[Music]
we see Saudi Arabia as the country of
oil and strict Islam where women wear
wheels and kisses are edited out from
films but suddenly there was a new Crown
Prince
he says he wants to reform the country
women get more rights and tourists will
soon be welcome the country has become
less dependent on oil
at the same time the people are ruled
with an iron fist
one wrong word can have serious
consequences in this year of changes I
travel around the country and follow the
developments on the inside Through The
Eyes of the citizens are they just empty
promises or is Saudi Arabia really able
to change
[Music]
now looks during before King berserk
and it was just foreign
from the earliest beginnings of Islam
Muslims have come to Saudi Arabia
one of the rules of Islam is to go to
the holy city of Mecca
pilgrims Mort and Jeddah Harbor
its holy cities such as Mecca and Medina
give Saudi Arabia power in the Islamic
world
the outer half and and aftermath is
sport
Muslims at North Africa they had them to
transport my augments are the
Netherlands India and it was just a
plaque by Aldi pelhams
and there is no States but foreign
foreign
I want to find out what they do with it
Samir is an official of Jeddah he guards
the city center and knows every alley
and every inhabitant
[Music]
he is the head of an important family
the king trusts them to guide the
pilgrims
and in 1937 King Abdel Aziz built this
it used to be just a a sand and we will
cross the Sand
this is the the steel oh yeah as a ship
and that's the level
but in the past this was a big business
and uh 90 of the pilgrims outside Arabia
they come from this point how many
people were coming in that time in the
early time maybe 50
000 a hundred thousand and and later on
but I think oh now is hundreds of
thousands and they come to 2 million
people they they come to to Pilgrim
[Music]
so this was the route of the pilgrims
yes we walk this way and then we enter
this gate the gate to Jeddah to the
market and to the city
this gate we call it alforda gate
alfoldagate yes and then this is
the last 200 years old Corridor so
thousands of people were walking yes
maybe every day yes this is the first
street days of how many kilometers is it
from here 70 kilos and by camel Caravan
it takes today two days from two days
yes now an hour and a half by car
but it gives also a huge responsibility
when millions of pilgrims come to this
country the future is humidity yes and
it's not very easy and Saudi Arabia is
gaining very good experience but Saudi
Arabia also can decide which way it goes
with religion okay but please don't ask
me about politics okay at all yes okay
Samir breaks off the discussion on
religion and power he is afraid to say
something that might damage his Affairs
Islam is the world's fastest growing
religion the number of pilgrims
increases all the time
Saudi Arabia does its best to manage the
visiting crowds
is industry
pilgrims pour into Mecca every year
landing at the special airport
during the Hajj the great animal
pilgrimage it's full to the brim
planes lent the rest of the year too for
the umrah the smaller pilgrimage that
can be done any time of year
most Pilgrims safe up for decades to
come here
a high point in their lives
[Music]
how important is the umra for you very
important this is a integral part of our
religion of the state is a religious
duty duty yeah it's one of the five
films if you can afford yeah then you
must go for hug once in a life
and then we go then we see the house of
God house of Allah and then we surround
so God has given the power to Saudi
Arabia because that's not the power but
I think it is a gift from God it's a
gift from God but it brings also a lot
of money
this is a gift of God yeah yeah it's a
gift here and how will you travel now
from here to Makkah by car you're not
going with the bus
foreign
the pilgrims are welcomed with a free
copy of the Quran and guide it towards
the buses in a practiced manner these
Pakistani pilgrims can afford a rental
car to go to Mecca
but rentals can't come to the airport
[Music]
what's the problem our car is waiting
outside outside he's not allowed to
enter this car in this premises okay so
the bus owner will not charge us if we
give number of that car okay
now there's no problem
they wait for someone to bring them
outside
they are stuck at the airport for now
[Music]
Samir takes me to what he calls the most
beautiful spot in town so a horse or a
mule or a cannon can go up it is the old
city Palace where Abdel Aziz used to
have a study
founder of modern day Saudi Arabia
he had himself crowned King while
holding the Quran thus linking religion
and politics
foreign
so so the the Pelham route
that way this way which way that's it
you see look yeah yeah oh like this yes
from there all the way there
the cameras come to the house where the
pilgrims stayed and then they go to the
gate of Makkah which is in Jeddah and
then they registered the rock hard and
they give him permit and then they go
towards Makkah so you're from Jeddah all
your life you saw pilgrims in Jeddah yes
yes and you and your father and your
grandfather and yes
when I was young I did sell water two
pilgrims next to the Old Airport
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and and we burn the coffee light
it's a difficult time now in the world
for Muslims I will be the future for
Muslims it is difficult for the whole
world it's not only Muslims but yeah
that's true but we have we had a lot of
troubles because of what happened in 9
11 but also Dash yeah they are not
Muslims
they are criminals they pretend to be
Muslim in the Islamic religion if you
call one person like you kill the whole
world
Samir rejects the crimes committed in
the name of Islam
he rejects all negative images created
around his faith
he followed the route he showed me
this is also a personal Journey for me
with my background Mecca played a role
in my life too
[Music]
so I act like
on the mirror
to City
one of the habits during a pilgrimage is
to wear traditional clothes
and Iran consists of just two pieces of
fabric held together with a belt
symbol of simplicity the idea is that
all pilgrims are equal whether you are a
cleaner or a bank director
okay like this yeah
[Music]
our Pakistani pilgrims are allowed on
the bus
they are glad to get away from the
airport at last
today I witness what it does to these
people a mix of tension about the
journey and satisfaction that Mecca is
getting closer
is it a special location is it for
someone who is ill or you want to pray
for someone or is it just
for everything everything
safety of your life a safety of religion
for safety of your future for safety of
your evil life
then we will go back then we will be a
refined person well I hope you will be a
fine personally yes but you were not a
fine person no no we are but it will be
it's more refined you can say as I told
you earlier that it is just a renewal of
commitment to a man with God
going to Mecca is a sacrifice for some
pilgrims greater than for others
these men arranged a luxury car for
their Journey
will it ever get here
have a good trip
for foreign
foreign
s go to Medina first
it is the second holy city in Islam I
want to do that too and get permission
from the authorities we are even allowed
to film on strict conditions
[Music]
science says Haram area meaning
non-muslims are not allowed here
in Atlanta
and
[Music]
hope numbers were recommend for any
photos and I used to do a Daily Tech
evening
sadly in order to film in Medina I have
to go without one of the crew
now
for Muslims
it's
understood Medina yes
and
um
this is my first time in a strictly
Muslim area
Medina is where the Prophet Muhammad
lived and was buried
[Music]
this Friday is
foreign
the remainders of the famous hijaz
Railway line are here
[Music]
it ran from Turkey to Medina but is now
closed
hundreds of thousands of pilgrims came
from the north by train hello how are
you
I'm fine
you go to Istanbul can I come with you
you're on travel or Umbra or yeah
judging by his Entourage this is a
dignitary on a day trip
turns out to be the minister of Muslim
affairs from Singapore I come here to
meet my counterpart from the Kingdom of
Saudi to negotiate our annual Hajj Kota
and all the arrangements for the Hajj
the number of programs in Singapore is
quite small actually based on the quota
we used to have only 680. last year
alhamdulillah with our negotiation up to
800. so there is a quota for every
country yes wow yeah so we have to work
within that quota but my problem now is
that a lot more singaporeans people will
be programming more affluent one to come
to Hajj so if you register now the
waiting time is 34 years 34 years yes
wow literally so it also can make people
sad who are waiting for a very long time
exactly so we always have a situation
where we have someone who has never been
there he's an elderly he wants to go but
you need someone to look after him so he
brings his son the son goes to the look
of after the father then the son gets
married he wants to go with his wife but
he's considered a second family where
the wife is the first time so all these
complications you know because we give
priority to first timer and people who
wants to fulfill it because you know
it's the fifth pillar took Islam
doing the Hajj is a rare opportunity
it is best to be on good terms with
Saudi Arabia because they decide how
many pilgrims they will admit
that's the East mosque the Easter
and Authority
I am allowed to join the call for prayer
side door takes me into the oldest
mosque in the world
um
put this in the mosque
[Music]
oh you do here microphone yeah
okay
yep
you will do that as an hour yeah
[Music]
and
um
foreign
[Music]
further into the mosque I'm surprised
find a wedding ceremony
Union
is made between the groom and the Father
of the Bride
this is a marriage inside the mosque
it's what you say it's a contract
you know we can make it anyway but we
prefer to make it the most so this is
official yes professional
how many wives you can have in Saudi
Arabia no in Islam in the end you are
allowed to
because
this country is the Cradle of Islam
it gives Saudi Arabia a crucial position
in religious reform
but the ultra Orthodox ideas are often
expressed openly
is
your watch
I get permission to visit an important
advocate of moderate Islam Adil
al-kalbani the former Imam of the great
mosque Mecca
he is highly regarded by the faithful
and a known supporter of reform
[Music]
foreign
I see women without scarf what do you
think about it
do you like music
[Music]
how do very Orthodox people react on you
is
[Music]
but is this the time for change sir no
yeah I don't know
is a spiritual leader who admits that
salafism the Orthodox School of Islam is
a source for the ideologies of groups
like Isis and Al-Qaeda he would like an
open debate to combat extremism
is
a group like daesh is that salafi
foreign
tries to hold on to salafism while
seeking to join the Modern Age
this causes constant friction
I am getting close to Mecca when I come
across an unexpected scene
foreign
[Music]
enter here
in checkpoints
and and that is
um
foreign
is close to non-muslims this is strictly
supervised
agrees that this must not be meddled
with
he even takes it a step further there is
no room for two religions on the Arabian
peninsula
is
foreign
this attitude was the reason that during
a tour of Western European cities in
2015 he was denied access and called a
hate preacher
tonight
foreign
he has not changed his opinions since
that speech in 2015. what's more he does
not reject violence if Islam is
Disturbed
uh
foreign
[Music]
these people are supposed to boost
religious reforms the Imam with the
reputation of a reformer proclaims views
that don't sit well with the West
I leave these ideas behind and go find
the origins of Islam
alongside dozens of foreign pilgrims I
climb Mount Noor in Mecca
[Music]
is
in a cave on top of this mountain the
prophet Muhammad had his first
revelation in the year 610 the angel
Gabriel came to him and designated him
as Allah's prophet
[Music]
foreign
how's it
outside
[Music]
and
now I like the top right
I used to provide mohammediated
foreign
stayed on this rock for almost two years
overlooking the Kaaba
pilgrims won't be deterred
they want to be in the same room as him
[Music]
foreign
conflicted
[Music]
this very modern stuff
Phil neubau
type in a Subway
Pizza Hut
yeah and notice
I'll go over here
for us and that that's your investors
after a long journey from the Red Sea
Coast and through Medina we are here at
last Mecca
in my childhood it took on mythical
proportions finally I get to see it for
myself
[Music]
and it is
foreign
permission to film for 50 minutes in
this Square
[Music]
is
Muslims
the millions of pilgrims flocking to the
great mosque every year are accommodated
in the hotels around the square
there are more to come new hotels shoot
up everywhere
um
tell room I prepare for the umrah the
smaller pilgrimage I will walk around
the Kaaba seven times
I have a Sufi background one of the many
Islamic branches
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
by the flow of people moving to the
Kaaba
that velvet clutch shrine
the devotion of these pilgrims is
overwhelming they want to absorb every
second they turn a blind eye to filming
on a mobile phone
all right
[Music]
I've died from
foreign
[Music]
my journey is done
I saw the Kaaba pictured on my
grandfather's Rock from up close
I saw the Rapture of the pilgrims who
reached Mecca at long last
the attraction of the holy cities give
Saudi Arabia religious powers
it is a mainly conservative country
while there could be a driving force
behind reforms
there is a long way to go before this
country becomes a beacon of religious
tolerance
[Music]
this afternoon Paradise
Oak
immensely
this is the untouched Saudi Arabia
over 200 islands in the Red Sea formed
the Pharisees and Islands
they are secluded hardly accessible for
Saudis
now drama
and Oak be safe
it is odd to travel through this country
not noticing the Raging war in the
neighboring country Yemen
as is often the case Saudi Arabia is
trying to mask reality
the unspoiled pharahs and islands are
the pride of the country
only few Saudis have been there
but 1200 kilometers away at the Annual
Festival in Riyadh visitors Google at
Island's recreated Beauty
here the polished version of the country
is on display
it attracts many Rich families with
mates
a lot of people from Philippines here
yeah
can you ask her what makes her proud
about Saudi Arabia yeah
[Music]
okay thank you bye-bye so I need help
this is the age old Saudi Arabia brought
together in one area
everyone passes through here
[Music]
even the religious police is present
they try to call visitors to prayer but
not everyone supports that
[Music]
and
foreign
the main event can be found further on
the newly acquired American weapons
so what type of helicopter is this this
is an ah-64 echo so this is a new weapon
new weapon and the new version of that
so what's the name of it that's the
missile we called it Hellfire Hellfire
yes Hellfire and it's the new design
which is Romeo Hellfire doesn't sound
very good
I agree yep
you're trained for this yes
is this a helicopter where Saudi Arabia
is proud of because they are showing
this to the people yes
we are really proud of us our Creed is
to defend our country
and Saudi Arabia buys a lot of weapons
there we know that because we have a new
deal with America and what you said so
to defend the country we need a lot of
weapons yes
did you also fight in Yemen No no no not
not you didn't I just finished my oh you
did just finish but are you gonna are
you gonna go
I'm not sure you're not sure
besides buying new weapons Saudi Arabia
wants to connect with the West in other
areas too
the Royal House says that they want
reform the question is how far they will
go
will civilians get voting rights
what about women's influence on the
policy
[Music]
shura resides in the city
they are the country's consultative
Council
it is comprised of representatives from
all regions
the king himself appoints them
the shura has a pioneering role in the
reforms
after months of negotiation I may now
take a look
this is the main hall yeah this is the
main hall and this is the for royal
family and the Ministers of the
government and the high religious people
this is the first section under this
section actually in the middle yes just
for the sure members that's 150 actually
and where does the Crown Prince sit he's
sitting with the god Mufti there
and what is the role of the grand Mufti
the government should ask him because if
to go to the Islamic rules principles or
not if not they will listen to him
actually for that it's a man
so he has a great influence then on
political issues also absolutely he has
a great influence and political issues
and this is because Saudi Arabia is
Islamic country
will it be possible to choose shura
members you know you you shouldn't deal
with us here like we in Europe we need
time to develop the way of thinking then
you can we can talk about election right
now in my in my belief but let me say
they could be elected what type of
people will be insured on them it will
be a tribal people tribal people because
we a tribal tradition here is very
strong in Saudi Arabia very conservative
people also conservative people I mean
the extremistry extremely so yeah
extremist people and their ideas
those kind of people would dominate I
believe the the council if they elected
so you're afraid of it that that type of
people
we're afraid about
developing our country we want to be a
modern country and modernity would come
with good ideas not with the traditional
ideas that bring uh you know
sectarianism and violence in the society
he believes free elections aren't
possible yet
it would bring extremism to the shura
the doors of the daily conference room
are opened for us
the 30 women that have been allowed in
for a few years sit here
is the highest consultative Council to
the king and it works as a Saudi version
of a parliament
we're chosen by the king at this point
you're sitting in Jetta at your home and
then you get a call do you go to the
kingdom yes you have to swear an oath
you have to swear an oath that you will
be serving
basically our religion our country and
our King does the king follow every
advice you you give as shura everything
is viewed upon by the king and obviously
it's up to him to decide what works best
for this certain situation I'm trying to
understand
it is called a parliament a Ashura isn't
elected King Salman himself decides
whether or not to take the advice Lena 2
questions the value of free elections
would be your next step to be chosen by
the people
possibly right now I don't think we're
ready but maybe later on part of it
would be by elections that we say that
there was a possibility to to be chosen
that would it then be able to have 30
women in the in the shooter if you would
Maybe not maybe if it was uh by voting
we wouldn't get a chance to represent uh
basically 20 for sure so this is the
minimum it is definitely uh not possible
for us to go below 20 so there are
benefits from nominations
Lena is dependent on the appointment of
the king
mainly regions far from Riyadh want to
stick to tradition
travel to this area which is difficult
to enter
so this will work a bit
on the shock
this part of the country is linked with
the terrorism of 9 11.
hijackers that attacked the Twin Towers
and Pentagon are rooted here
15 of the 19 hijackers were from Saudi
Arabia
a funny fact in campus
a
dorpius in days of Allah
in all the doors is
criteria
foreign
[Music]
The Villages are spread out over the
valleys
on Tuesday Morning many villagers come
together at the market in the province
Capital Abba
Farmers head over from the countryside
to sell their products
yes
foreign
yeah just totally
before no money no Patrol
Saudi Arabia
now it's good than before because the
people get money he make big houses
before the house is this small
um
so if the king's chain wants to change
something
foreign
[Music]
various tribes lay down the law
it is difficult for the Saudi government
to get the villagers to join the reforms
what happens if you touch the government
why why is it dangerous
it's just a woman this is
dangerous
is it allowed to walk with the daggers
is it allowed to walk with the gun
yes yes Wow have one yeah
further on South I drive over the
country's highest mountain ridges houses
are skillfully built against the slopes
there is a narrow road connecting The
Villages
the area is divided among local tribes
they mostly keep quiet
I try to contact a local farmer to learn
more about these traditions
[Music]
foreign
salute
um
foreign
[Music]
a few miles away I seek out the highest
point in the area
um
okay
this is
a few dozen miles away a horrible Civil
War has been raging for over three years
much to the despair of civilians who try
to survive
Saudi Arabia in the
clubs and
as animals
has turned into a war between an
International Coalition under direction
of Saudi Arabia and the rebels who are
supported by Arch Enemy Iran
despite peace negotiations the war
threatens Millions with famine
and as foreign
[Music]
the war is far away from Riyadh it is a
different world
not a word is sad about Yemen during the
presentation of vision 2030.
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman's
ambitious plan
announces the economic social and civil
reforms
[Music]
it all sounds great
but once I return from the unruly South
I want to know if these plans are
realistic and how far they go
first I visit Lena at the sports grounds
she set up herself
she's willing to discuss the future of
the country how long does this exist
open games for girls basketball since
2003 it's been running of course we've
expanded a lot since then Saudi Vision
2030 clearly states that it is the
objective to increase
you know participants in sports from 13
to 40 percent then we talk about
islamically like sports and Islam it's
huge you look into the second pillar of
Islam which is Salah yeah
[Music]
they sit there I think it's a little bit
quieter okay
all about what you're standing you're
sitting you're gaming you're constantly
moving and then also like the love like
Hajj
these reforms
are they real or is it window dressing
I'm a big supporter of the you know
social reforms of division 2030 a lot of
the economic reforms
would you support reforms on human
rights
well we have a human rights committee in
the sugar Council that you can talk to
and they deal with the human rights
related issues that's not my committee
but they're active
our view about Saudi Arabia is what's in
the news and Saudi Arabia is mostly in
the news with negative things as we know
now with what happened with the
journalists
whose fault is that
they're not serious yeah I mean I'm not
honestly this whole thing about my part
was not about answering anything related
to this because at this point it's
something that we're still waiting for
it to unfold do you know what I mean so
I don't want to
um okay something very
like sensitive and we're okay okay Lena
we just leave that
um this is the tension among the Saudi
population even shura members
Lena doesn't want to jeopardize her
position
sticks to the Royal House's official
story
do you think that the death penalty
needs also a reform
we do not question God sent laws
when you talk about the capital
punishment
punishment is the capital punishment you
know there will not change that's not
that will never change because this is
um a country that's Constitution is the
the Holy Quran and the prophet saying so
obviously there are things that are God
said that we cannot change
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
I head to the museum
for a specific reason
not to see even more portraits of the
Kings
my eyes
the complaints
I had there to get closer to the square
in front of the Museum without suspicion
it was the location for the most heinous
scenes
locally it is known by the irreverent
name Chop Chop Square
on this the blackout was a
the dog stuff out foreign
so um
foreign
city has a square like this
Nationwide there are dozens of
executions each year
in very few cases the executions aren't
carried out after the order is revoked
like in this case
now plan is
foreign
it's an appalling practice which I found
incomprehensible
one of the most important lawyers in the
Middle East
wants to clarify the death penalty for
me
and there is uh yeah first he wants to
show me the city in his Rolls Royce why
don't you have a driver no no but no
anybody
but my car you know I did but they drive
by car okay I have a driver for myself
dream to go to school but my car is
exactly this car no nobody can drive
with me that's me yeah is it difficult
to work as a lawyer in Saudi Arabia not
too much you know everything about the
Sharia law also
um you know our law our studying in
Saudi Arabia it's also from Sharia
two back different between law and Syria
not too big
foreign
[Music]
this is all prizes you want
yeah this is all my history
it's nice
on which occasion you can get the death
penalty in Saudi Arabia film on the
Caribbean
is
almost 14 centuries old is it not
outdated
foreign
the one who resides the death penalty
can he ask for execution behind walls or
is it always a public execution
[Music]
the death penalty especially the public
executions meet resistance in the West
according to the lawyer despite the
reforms this will remain untouched
when it's a public execution they see it
as cruel in Europe they see it as a act
against human rights what what is your
opinion on that
is
okay but we we don't give bloggers in
Europe 15-year sentence
and also we don't give that penalty to
woman rights activists
foreign
[Music]
distorted in favor of Saudi Arabia
according to the lawyer bloggers are put
in jail for being spies
another reality Saudi Arabia doesn't
acknowledge his poverty
which affects many citizens and
immigrants
I notice it in various districts in the
country
we can only sneakily film it
[Music]
okay
this is
acting ghetto
porn worker situation in particular is
suppressed further by the reforms
10 million out of the 20 million Saudis
are foreign workers
do you speak English
yes where are you from
foreign
must leave the country soon
the Royal house has decided their jobs
should be fulfilled by Saudis
the Chamber of Commerce is trying to Aid
that cause
I can work in a marketing department I
can do editing
and to be fair made like life is not
like finding a job making life in Saudi
is not that hard the unemployed mohanet
studied Marketing in England
he has returned to find a well-paying
job
the government wants to put him to work
but if you don't have a job here does
the state give you money if you're not
working just in my case they give you
like about 20 2500. that's mean 2500
real a month a month which is like dude
I smoke yeah okay I own a Jeep so is the
youth a little bit spoiled here yeah I
would say yes obviously not everyone
have the same circumstances I'm
surrounded with you know just everybody
is Rich not everybody is Rich everybody
is having a good day okay
he is one of the 1.3 million
beneficiaries the state wants to put to
work
media with media practice and production
I'm looking for steady incomes
tries to get himself a good offer
chances are he will still have to accept
a job he doesn't want
we are working on on the mindset of of
ours as the parents and the brothers
that okay this is this is lower level
lower level jobs like sales and and so
we are changing mindset it changed
actually with the entry of females are
changing
the head of recruiting is open about
their policies
I start to realize what the reforms will
mean for foreign workers
if the plans move forward the city will
look different
what's the impact on foreign workers who
have to leave this country the impact is
is positive one of the major impacts the
money would be spent here because we're
hiring local now if you if you just go
to the statistics we are second country
where money goes outside but it's also a
little bit harsh to send them away
it is it is as I said it's not it's not
an easy to to leave them go it's not we
are happy that they're leaving but
sometimes we have to take it the hard
way there is no emotion at the end it's
an economy
and the people who don't want to leave
but have to leave how's that going
believe me the people who's being here
for more than 25 years yeah they're
having higher standard living than here
the maids example I see a Trillium
example Indonesia mate after 25 years
she will go there she's having a bitter
house than the house that you're working
here
after dozens of years working Saudi
Arabia is trying to send the workers
back
they didn't have many rights but now
even their right to stay is taken away
but is it possible that I will see a
Saudi who's cleaning in this country
there is there is there is wow okay if
you go to if you go to wedding hall at
night okay the Saudis are serving okay
especially the female there is I'm
saying it's not it's not we are not shy
of way of cleaning we are cleaning our
houses we are taking care of our plants
but in terms of public cleaning yeah we
are we're big we still need it but why
do we see it as modern slavery
this is your point of view as a European
and American it's it's not for here for
us in this region it's normal it's it's
a it's a relation of employee and
employer relation I'm just brought here
to to work at home she's having her
right but at the same thing she's not
the home owner but that's not the same
rights as a Saudi has
Saudis doesn't work as a homemade
many things remain the same but the
effects of the reforms remain uncertain
to many
I unexpectedly get a message from the
lawyer
he wants to invite me to dinner at his
house before I leave Saudi Arabia
we are joined by one of his colleagues
this is traditional yeah
what's the name of this food it has a
special name she
she take four hours but the fire and you
close it and after four hours you open
it and then this wow it's ready yeah
I had a lot of interviews and now it's
more difficult and I think it has to do
with the story of the journalists maybe
after the dinner we can talk everything
before that we can't talk
I am taken to a side room
the call for an international
investigation into the death of kasoji
still exists
I try to bring it up
okay can we talk yeah or if I eat up if
I eat this I die I swear to you
so Mr Khalid the case of the journalist
khashoggi were almost the whole world is
talking about it foreign
but why not the independent inquiry
with
Kelly Islam
foreign
that's the end of the discussion for
them they'd rather discuss the future
new projects that have been announced by
the kingdom like the megalomaniacal naom
I is a new project that it's on the Red
Sea and very strategic place with the
best weather in the Arabian Peninsula
open areas free zones open the trade for
all the uh the Middle East also for
tourism yeah yes
hurry up
the name is that the most important
project for the coming years for Saudi
Arabia yeah we are talking about 500
billion dollars in that project
the reforms will not turn back uh I
don't think so because it's not a reform
actually This Is Us exactly This Is Us
they sent me North to the plains on
which neon will be built
a big plan to make a state filled with
entertainment and free play
the Crown Prince tries to keep his power
in spite casoji's murder
all hope is set on this project
it will be my last trip through Saudi
Arabia
I will take what I have seen while
traveling here with me the hope the
wealth the Despair and the poverty
Saudi Arabia sketches a future which
they hope the West will believe
[Music]
for now
all I see is Desert
[Music]
entertainment
and at this Saudi Arabia in Detroit
is
foreign
as long as Saudi Arabia is an absolute
monarchy supported by spiritual leaders
and as long as the Sharia governs
the divide with the West will remain
the reforms hardly help that
but I realize that in a country where
women and activists are oppressed every
step towards freedom is welcome
foreign
[Music]